was sagt julian kuhn nach dem sex und
damit herzlich willkommen bei wann im
moment ihre kommentare
was meint ihr momentaner von gut
raumhoch daumen hoch ich bin ja schon
dabei hier kannst du nicht einfach ein
weder vormachen und das tun hat ob das
dein neues format b
na klar kann ich das
ich kann dieses kennzeichen nett aber
das doch ganz leicht schau mal mama ggg
ist nicht so dein ding gdg was soll das
heißt teile gelbe guten ludwigshafen
gegen gorilla was heißt ggg kannst du zu
den video games inc
ja na klar hast du auf dem splash
nein ich feier dieses jesus bild im
hintergrund einfach hand welches jesus
bild im hintergrund
du meinst mein vater mein name ist - und
ich habe einen anzug an weil einer mal
bei photoshop lange warte ich bin aber
mirjam ott ihre nutzen
nein ich rede nicht mit meinem jesus
bilderrahmen
ich will mit baby da die parodie sehen
das wäre göttlich armen
ich habe viel mehr geld als ich für ihn
mehr geld als du aber wetten ich kann
diesen dolly viel schneller als du wenn
ich haye und nun die besten tweets der
letzten woche kopf wer ist da macht des
mond christ alt wir machen
egal wie nas du warst mal wanne vanessa
von wem sie diese großartigen tut auch
von mir selbst folgt mir auf twitter es
lohnt sich denn es beginnt
ich hoffe euch hat diese folge wanne
moment ihre kommentare gefallen
und wenn ja dann könnt ihr mir
vielleicht ein daumen nach oben geben
dann freut es mich
und vergiss nicht immer kommentar
einzuschreiben damit ich dann auch was
dafür habe und tschüss